let's get to this clip that producer
Jacob pulled this clip is from the 2012
HBO series really cutting edge stuff
producer Jake that's great 2012 HBO
series The Newsroom oh that's that awful
show written by that awful writer uh
Aaron Sorkin you better lawyer where one
of the characters will McAvoy explains
why America is not the greatest country
on Earth it's got 10 million views on
YouTube okay take it away let's move on
to the next question go ahead hi my name
is Jenny I'm a sophomore and this is for
all three of you can you say in one
sentence or less what
um you know what I mean
can you say why America is the greatest
country in the world
diversity and opportunity Louis
freedom and freedom so let's keep it
that way
will
the New York Jets
no I'm gonna hold you to an answer on
that
what makes America the greatest country
in the world
well Lewis and Sharon said it diversity
and opportunity and freedom and freedom
you don't look satisfied
I want a human moment from you
what about the people
why is it not the greatest country in
the world Professor that's my answer
you're saying yes
let's talk about fine the Sharon the Nea
is a loser yeah it accounts for a penny
out of her paycheck but he gets to hit
you with it anytime he wants it doesn't
cost money it costs votes it costs air
time and column inches you know why
people don't like liberals because they
lose if Liberals are so smart how come
they lose so damn always this is how you
know it's a liberal show
in politics always when one is trying to
seem like he's being critical of both
sides one criticizes the other side for
being evil and wrong and malicious and
terrible and criticizes his own side for
being ineffective very rarely does
someone criticize his own side for
having some mistaken premises or falling
for some bad ideas or even making errors
and engaging in sin usually what it will
be is oh you guys are the bad guys and
we're the weak guys we just don't know
how to win so that so he's framing this
way because the Liberals our biggest
problem we just lose we're not strong
what are you talking about you control
the media you control the the
bureaucracy the military the university
Corporate America everything you control
all everything well we just don't have
any power why because like occasionally
Kevin McCarthy becomes the speaker of
the house for five seconds and can't
really get anything done high five oh
wow yeah you're right you guys don't
have any power sure okay keep going and
with a straight face you're gonna tell
students that America is so
Star-Spangled awesome that we're the
only ones in the world who have freedom
Canada has Freedom Japan has Freedom the
Canada one didn't really age well
because Canada is now like possibly the
most tyrannical worst country on Earth
where a dictator Trudeau comes in and
shuts down those poor truckers and locks
up pastors this did not age well at all
and it didn't age well because Aaron's
organ is a big lib and doesn't know
anything about anything uh thank you so
his predictions don't come true because
they're not in accord with reality but
if his criticism is of freedom in the
abstract I'm actually half with him so
keep going the UK France Italy Germany
Spain Australia Belgium as Freedom so
207 sovereign states in the world like
180 of them have freedom all right and
yeah you uh Sorority Girl just in case
you accidentally wander into a voting
booth one day there's some things you
should know and one of them is there is
absolutely no evidence to support the
statement that we're the greatest
country in the world we're seventh in
literacy 27th in math 22nd in science
49th in life expectancy 178th and infant
mortality sure whatever blah blah blah
you've got these statistics the reason
that this rant that you hear not just
from the Sorkin character but from from
liberals all the time we're not the
greatest we're the twelfth in Reading in
the 11th and whatever you know the
reason you know that's fake is because
we're the most powerful we control the
world we're we are at least for now the
superpower on Earth
and we're the country that everybody
wants to go to so that is prima fascia
evidence that we are the great we are
the greatest we have the the most
greatness
I am so it actually goes back to Carl
Jung Carl Jung says that different
nations are motivated by different
things Germany is motivated by the idea
France is motivated by Glory England is
motivated by the gentlemen these
defining concepts for these nations and
what is America's America's greatness
that's why Donald Trump's slogan was
make America great again this is why he
took that from Ronald Reagan Ronald
Reagan's like it was make America great
again that is the idea and it has worked
because generally people get what they
want what they're after now there are
things that are more important than
greatness in a terrestrial sense there's
holiness
there's sanctity there are other things
I'm not saying that America is without
faults by any means but this is just a
stupid rant the fact that we control the
entire world and that all the people
want to come here and they're flooding
across our borders three and a half
million per year plus another million
legally is the proof that we are the
greatest country on Earth it's
indisputable right now go to
grillblazer.com are you tired of waiting
ages for your grill to heat up now you
can say goodbye to those tedious moments
of impatiently watching charcoal burn
and say hello to instant barbecue
satisfaction thanks to our new friends
at Grill Blazer Grill Blazers Grill guns
are designed to do everything from
expertly searing your Meats to lighting
charcoal grills wood stoves outdoor
fireplaces just about anything you can
think of that you need a high power fire
to solve for a problem I would also
recommend sparking up stogies that way
especially if your cigar is like a 400
ring Gauge by 18 inch long cigar roll
Blazer is a great way to do it they've
got two guns the Grogan basic high
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and Wood Grill and smokers burns up to 3
600 Degrees so it'll probably take care
of what you need 30 inch flame pretty
serious and the sous vide gun has a
shorter Barrel perfect for professional
Culinary Kitchen uses from gently
caramelizing brulee or other sugars
fruits to rapidly searing steaks outside
on the grill head on over right now let
your grilling Adventures begin visit
growblazer.com use promo code knows for
15 off your order grillblazer.com
for 15 off your order third in median
household income number four in labor
force and number four in exports we lead
the world in only three categories
number of incarcerated citizens per
capita number of adults who believe
angels are real can you believe these
stupid idiots who believe angels are
real like um St Thomas Aquinas and Saint
Augustine and uh every smart person
who's ever lived statistically but not
Aaron's Orkin I guess who do you think
has a better review of reality who do
you think's got got a little more
ticking around in between the old years
Thomas Aquinas one of the most
intelligent people ever in human history
or some Hollywood TV hack writer I I
fold like a cheap thing that you know
that folds really easily yeah we believe
that there is such a thing as spiritual
reality one of the evidences for
Spiritual reality would be the
intelligibility of the universe and the
fact that the things that we most care
about in the world are not material and
physical but metaphysical our loves our
hopes our dreams our intuitions of an
ultimate intelligence that makes the
world intelligible the the intuition of
a Divine logic of the universe a
recognition that some things
are not rational like my Tumblr here and
some things or have rational soul and
body are are Composites of the two
hylomorphic and then there are other
creatures that are not corporeal but Are
Spiritual entirely yeah I know you're
right you totally debunked all of
philosophy and theology Aaron Sorkin
great good job 26 countries combined 25
of whom are allies now none of this is
the fault of a 20 year old college
student but you nonetheless are without
it on a member of the worst period
generation period ever period so when
you ask what makes us the greatest
country in the world I don't know what
the you're talking about
Yosemite
Yosemite is nice
sure used to be
you stood up for what was right
we fought for moral reasons we passed
laws struck down laws for moral reasons
we waged Wars on poverty not poor people
there it is there it is
he says we but we used to be great
and when were we great
in the 1960s
[Music]
that was it
I'm a boomer Hollywood writer
and that's my thesis we weren't great in
1620 weren't great in 1776 weren't great
in the 1860s we weren't great even
really in the maybe starting in the
second world war we start but it was the
60s
back when we had the Weather Underground
blowing people up for radical leftist
causes back when we decided to dismantle
a lot of our institutions and back when
we decided to rewrite the Constitution
and turn away from God and start just
engaging in all sorts of completely
debashed behaviors everywhere and
coincidentally actually
starting at the place where all of those
test scores that I and all of those
statistics that I previously cited for
evidence of America's decline right at
the very moment that they all started to
decline that was
that was when we were really great it
doesn't add up we sacrificed we cared
about our neighbors we put our money
where our mouths were and we never beat
our chest we built great big things made
ungodly technological advances explored
the universe cured diseases and we
cultivated the world's greatest artists
yeah we never beat our chest we never oh
no not Americans
we haven't always been known for beating
our chest at least starting in the early
19th century
up through Donald Trump yeah no that's
not a defining feature of the American
character of course it is it's always
been a defining feature we made the
greatest art oh yeah look man I'm as
patriotic as they come okay and I think
America actually has made some
contributions to art
but
come on man you're gonna compare Jackson
Pollock to Bernini I don't think so we
reached for the Stars
[Music]
acted like men we aspired to
intelligence we didn't belittle it it
didn't make us feel inferior
[Music]
we didn't identify ourselves by who we
voted for in the last election and we
didn't
scare so easy
put a pause there has never been a time
when Aaron Sorkin did not identify
himself by who he voted for in the last
election never never once we were able
to be all these things and do all these
things because we were informed
by great men men who were revered
first step in solving any problem is
recognizing there is one
America is not the greatest country in
the world anymore
so what's the better country I guess
that that's the answer he's got to give
I I totally agree America's got all
sorts of problems not the problems he
identifies but America does have all
sorts of problems one of whom is him
and his way of thinking and his way of
viewing the country but
if you make the claim America's not the
greatest country in the world
which I'm totally open to hearing what's
the alternative
just tell me the country France China
Namibia
if you can't give an answer to that then
the argument kind of falls apart and he
can't give an answer and his argument
I I suspect I I feel unraveled from the
very beginning as is always the case
with Mr Sorkin okay that's our show I'm
Michael Knowles this the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
Nation